at the Mobile World Congress robots that
cook and phones that fold like the new
launch by Chinese firm honor are being
sidelined by the technology you can't
hold particularly the metaverse
essentially the internet in 3D
companies are racing to develop
immersive experiences across all sectors
in education gaming planning and Retail
with 88 of global organizations now
investing in Technologies to create
virtual environments like in this
virtual retail space where real
salespeople can interact with customers
what we're seeing is from this kind of
explosion of initial interest is focused
now on real value use cases so we
actually interviewed a lot of our
clients a couple of months ago about
this about 3 000 Executives and we ask
them how much revenue are you going to
get from metaverse in the next three
years so not 10 years time and they said
over four percent of their revenue so
it's a significant amount of money and
if you look at that cross industry it's
about a trillion dollars in the next
three years from metaverse services
some people will have already
experienced the metaverse and online
avatars through the world of gaming but
what startups here are doing are
creating avatars for employees so I've
created this one who looks vaguely like
me and inside a virtual conference room
with features like real-time
interpretation this could transform the
world of work
other Transformations are more behind
the scenes here I'm troubleshooting in a
virtual semiconductor Factory it could
be the digital twin of a physical
Factory this is the industrial metaverse
where real machines factories buildings
cities and transport networks are
mirrored in the virtual world because in
the digital environment problems can be
found and fixed quickly increasing
productivity and reducing costs as
companies take their first baby steps
into the metaverse people like Susie
Mercer are there to guide them we're
still at very early days at the moment
so clients are very much experimenting
in this space but we are very clear on
what the impact is going to have on that
business so we're experimenting but
we're experimenting to understand what
the potential impact can be for those
businesses and then we'll scale where
it's benefit you know where it's
beneficial whether it benefits the
organization will scale and some will be
great and will scale somewhere
so while its true value is not yet clear
it is clear the metaverse is here to
stay Charlie Angela Al Jazeera Barcelona